Yle Areena.
[musiikkia]
- Anja Kuuppo, ikä 83. Luin tässä Helsingin sanomasta taas tästä vanhukset ja digi ja niiden käyttö.
Ja minun mittani tulee niin viimeiseen saakka täyteen. Kysymys on siitä, haluatko käyttää näitä laitteita vai et. Ei ole kysymys siitä, olisitko osannut vai et. Kysymys on et halua. Menee samaan rytmiin ja ryhmään.
En ole koskaan juonut viinaa kun en halua. En ole tupakoinut kun en halua. Meneekö tämä nyt jo loppujen lopuksi teidän päättäjien päähän? Kiitos.
No nyt toivotaan, että päättäjillä on halua kuunnella juuri tuo viesti, että menee sanoma perille sen sijaan, että sille kävisi kuin sorsan selkään tipahtavalle vesipisaralle. Minä toivotan oikein hyvää kesänviettoa. Sitähän ei voi tarpeeksi alleviivata. Se on Kansan Radio ja Lasse Olkinuora tässä Tervehdys. Onko popeda popeda ilman patea? Pitäisikö viinaa kuljettaa kotiin? Miksi verotoimistossa tuuttaa aina varattua? Muun muassa niitä aiheita kommentoidaan.
Tästä tulevan puoli tuntisen aikana. Nyt tähän aika alkuun vähän kierrosta pitkin Suomea. Mitkä asiat mietityttää nyt juhannuksen jälkeen kaksituhatta kaksikymmentäkuusi?
No missä ne keskimääräistä huonommat kuljettajat ovat jos keskimääräistä paremmat kuljettajat ajaa tällä lailla? Ja raskaan liikenteen ahut eivät pysy talvella tielle. Mikäs siinä on? Onko se tie sitten välillä muuttunut paikasta toiseen kun kukko ajaa se raskaan liikenteen autolla ojaan? Ei kai vaan näitä suomalaisia autoita vai vain luulotauti? Terveisiin ekaan.
-Hei, Kristian täällä. Tietysti haluan puhua tästä asuntomarkkinasta täällä Pirkanmaalla suunnalla, että mikä siinä on, että keski-ikäinen mies ei saa vuokra-asuntoa Tampereen seurulta ja Nokiaan seurulta, että kukaan ei ole yhtään mitään yhteyksiä. Tuntuu, että on vallalla semmoinen, että sorsitaan keski-ikäistä miestä. Ei mitään tanssia saada asuntoa. Ja sama on työmarkkinaa, että sorsitaan keski-ikäistä miestä. Eikö kokeilutta ammatilta ja toista työmiesta saa mihinkään töihin?
Kuka näin kaikkia voi? Nakellaan niskoja tuolla tällaista asiaa. Okei, moi.
-Kirkakka-Itä Suomesta. Minkä takia ei taloyhtiössä kesäaikaan pidetä ilmanvaihtoa suurella?
Ikäihmiset sairastelevat. Toivon taloyhtiöille laittakaa ilmanvaihtoa suurelle.
-No se on Samppa Rovaniemeltä. Hyvää päivää. -Joo, osaamisen taso laskee Suomessa. Ammatillisesta koulutuksesta puuttuu lukuvuoden verran opettajaohjausta ja muuta sellaista.
Nyt täytyy oikeasti miettiä Suomeen suunta, että se on todella ikääpä, että tällaisesta suoritettavasta portasta vähennetään paukkuja ja osaamista.
Samalla tulee ulkomallista työvoimaa, jolloin verotulot valuvat sitten ulkomaille. Ja tämähän ei ole tietenkään Suomen kannalta hyvä suunta. Suunta pitää muuttua, että osaamisesta ei saa leikata ja vaikka nyt tulee laivatilauksia ja muita, niin kun jotenkin tällaiset tutkimus- ja tuotekehittely on varaa näihinkin panostaa, syntyy nyt uusia työpaikkoja.
Ei mulla muuta. Kiitoksia. Hei hoi hii hoi vanha ex tykistä prikaatiloiden satakunnasta päivää ja moro. Tuota poliittinen katsaus Suomen tilanteesta kokonaisuudessaan ja näin lyhyesti. Kokoomus tekee aivan järkyttävää politiikkaa. Petteri Orpo ei ole saanut mitään muuta kuin kurjuutta aikaan näinä aikoina. Perussuomalaiset tietenkin kantavat osan tästä vastuun, ainakin kallupeitten mukaan, mitä nykkysin katsoo, kun vaalit lähestyvät ammattilta.
Eipä sen puoleen demareista nyt ja siellä sanotaan joitakin näistä ministeriä. Kenestä pääministeri ja sitten Lindtmanista sitten, että mikä olisi demareittenkin suuri salaisuus sitten näissä laskelmissa ja mitä myydään, mitä ei, koska velkahakelahan kuitenkin käy ja kasvaa ja mitä on käynyt meidän nuorisotyöttömyydelle. Siitä ollaan kovin huolissaan, mutta mitään ei tapahdu. Hyvin ristiriitaista lausuntoja he tekivät.
Kerrottuna näihin aloitteisiin, että kyllä näytelmä on kovaa ja mitäkohan vuoden päästä sitten meillä onkaan? Otaksun, että sota jatkuu. Olemme huonossa tilassa. Puolustusmenosta kasvaa. Sote leikkaa kiinni länsipohjaa, elikkä Merilappia myöten. Porissakin meni jo meri. Pori, terkkarit kaikki kiinni ja loppu. Todennäköisesti eduskunnan tärkeämpää nostaa omaa palkkaansa ja puoluetukea. Mitenkä huomattavasti?
Turtilaisille ei välttämättä kovin hyvä ole kuulunut ainakaan mitä. Olisi kivakunnan raporttia. Moro. Meille on saapunut lyhyt ja ytimekäs viesti, jossa harmitellaan, että eikö ketään muuta harmita hinnat esimerkiksi 4,99 tai 5,99. Pidetäänkö ihmisiä ihan idiotteina? Ja nyt seuraavaksi kun oikein tarkkaan kuuntelee, niin huomaa, että herättää moni muukin aihe ihan yhtä kookasta tulevaisuudessa.
Hyvä kunnetta, mikä saattaa tietysti olla hyvä asia. Eipähän ainakaan suhtaudu välinpitämättömästi asiaan, eipähän se asia ainakaan silloin ole merkityksetön.
Joka viihdeohjelmassa. Tässä tärkeimmät. Kiitos. - Täällä on Matti, terveä. Minua ärsyttää kamaa sinne yleinen televisiolaitoksessa olevat mainokset. Niitä on enemmän kuin mainosteja ja muissa mainoslaitoksissa yleensä. Jokahemmin. Uutisten välissä on kaikennäköistä timppulusta ja mainosta. Eikö ne voisi jättää, jos kertaan.
Esittäin tuota ärsyttää ne mainokset. On niin paljon sitten niitä ideohjelmia. Ei enää jatkaa. Kiitos, Tio. - Täällä on kyllä tuohtunut vanhus. On kallista pitää jonkun pankin asiakkuutta. Vanhus, joka on kuntonsa takia huono, ei pääse itse päivittäin asiakastietojaan eikä omista äälypuhelinta, ei tietokonetta, ei mihinkään.
Taksilla pitäisi lähteä. Lähteä avustaja mukana. Paperilomakkeen täytteen täytyy olla kopiohenkilökortista ja jonkun sekin on otettava. Siinäkin kun on apua pyydettävä, että tulostaa toiselle, niin jokaiselle sittenkin pitäisi jotakin palkkioantaa. Kyllä pelkkä paperilomake pitäisi.
Riittää tai jonkun henkilön pankista täytyisi ruveta käydä vanhuksien kotona päivittämässä nämä asiat. Miettikö joku muu samalla lailla kuin minä, että kyllä tämä on ihmeelliseksi mennyt. Tämä, että vanhuksia tällaiset pitäisi juoksuttaa. Kiitos ja hei.
Millä meinas korvat pudota kun kuulin näistä vieraslajien hävittämisestä? Lupinit tuolla maantien laidoissa nyt. Ne ovat kauniita. Maailma muuttuu, on ilmastonmuutoksen ja täällä on näitä pörjäisiinkin vieraslajeja ynnä muita eläimiä. Vaskitsa muun muassa ja nämä liito-oravat ja mitä onkaan.
Ja jos kotitelouksia ruvetaan sakottaa, että jo muutaman lupini on tontin laidassa, niin se on naurettavaa. Pitäkö hallitus todella meitä kansalaisia näin idiotin tyhmiä?
Apiinointia. Eihän popeiden ole ilman oikean ja popeiden laulussa listia, niin eihän se ole mitään. Kiitos ja hei.
Veroa maksat joka päivältä, vaikka auto seisoo enemmän pihassa kuin käyttää ajossa dieseliä. Maalla asuva eläkeläinen tarvitsee autoa päästäkseen kauppaan, lääkäriin, apteekkiin, kampaajaan. Ei eläkeläisellä ole mahdollisuutta, ettei tarvita ostaa uutta sähköautoa. Aina eläkeläiset unohdetaan kaikissa päätöksissä. Eläkeläisten verotus on kamalan korkea.
Kun mä silloin täällä kuuntelen kansanradiota, johtuukohan Suomen ongelma siitä, kun mä en ole koskaan käynyt äänestämässä eduskuntavaaleissa enkä kunnallisvaaleissa?
Jos sinä olisit käynyt äänestämässä, niin asiat olisivat paremmin.
No kun mä kyllä oikein uskon tuohon, mutta voiko... Ja eikö tuo äänestyskin ollut jo yli sata vuotta, niin onko tuo äänestys hyvä vai huono homma sitten? En oikein tiedä.
Niin. Mitäs meille sitten sen tilalle tulisi, jos ei ole tällaista äänestystä? No se on paha homma. Juiseahan aikuina on sanonut, että systeemi ei ole hyvä, mutta kuka kehittäisi paremman, ettei minulla katsoa mitään semmoista vastausta? Kyllä ole. Saako tentata sen verran, että minkä takia et äänestä? Mä pidän sitä hyödyttömänä. Niin. Ei ole vielä näkynyt sitä, mitä täällä on.
Mikäs aikuina lupasi sen Vappu Satasen tai sen aikainen pääministeri? Sitäkään ei ole tullut. Juu ei vielä. Sinä mielessä mä en usko tuohon äänestysjärjestelmään, että mä pidän sitä jotenkin vähän epäoikeudenmukaisena. Ehkä tuommoinen lempeä diktatuuri voisi olla paras hallintomalli, mutta... Onko sellainen mahdollista kuin lempeä diktatuuri? No ei se taida käytännössä kyllä olla. Niin.
Paperilla saattaa näyttää hyvältä, mutta... Niin kyllä kyllä. Mutta ei minulla tää varsinaisempaa asiaa, mutta minä tuohon äänestysjärjestelmään uskon. Olenhan mä jo kustuupine tyyppi, niin mitäs mä tässä vien ainakin kerran elämässä käydä äänestämässä? No sehän se olisi ensimmäistä kertaa kun sitten olisit. Niin se on. Pitäisikö sitä ennen katsoa kumminkin tää ilmari kiannon punainen viiva? Voi mikä se oli? Se oli salirattaat.
- No niin. - Mutta ei mulla tää on kummempaa. Hyvää paluun rikennettä jos joku on semmoista suorittamassa.
- Minä toivotan hyvät sunnun tai jatkot. - Joo, kiitos. - Kiitos, moi.
- Voi perkele. Tätähän minä pelejäsi. Nyt se alkaa se miinankuskaus kotiin ja se meni sillä lailla, että miinakuski tulee liikenteeseen ja ampulan -
lähtee liikenteestä pois, että sillä lailla silmuplee. - Päivää, päivää Kansanradio. Siellä oli eräs nuori mies, joka oli erään havainnon tehnyt, mikä pani minutkin nyt soittamaan tästä, että kuinka Suomessa hallitus ei ole kansaa varten vaan kansa hallitusta varten niin sanotusti. Jopa joo, näin ihan pitkälle menee ja tulee mieleen tässä kun ollaan Johannes Kastajan päivää, niin tässä -
sanotusti viettämässä 24. päivä ja mitenkä hänelle kävikään kun meni näitä valtiasta moittimaan vääryyksistä niin siellähän sitten hänen pää vaadittiin vadille, että olemmeko me menossa samaan suuntaan. Kaukana on demokratia, kansan suu vaiennetaan tavallaan toisella. Tämäkään on demokratia. Minä sanoisin, että tämä on oligarkia. Rikkaat, rikas, pieni porukka.
ja köyhät kitisee ja kuolee. Kiitos vaan tästä onnellisesta Suomesta. Hei, hei!
- Täällä on Jusku Unno täältä maakunnasta. Minua on ihmetellyt. Täällä tulla aamutievesku oli taas tällainen vasemmistovirteinen esitys, jotta maataloustuet on ava kuinka väärin tahansa, mutta se on vähän kummallinen juttu, kun EU erityisesti pitää maksaa maataloustukia kuluttua.
Ruuan hinnan alentamiseksi, mutta miksei sitä voisi tehdä vastaavaa systeemiä Palakka puolellekin, kun sitä kerrotaan, jotta maailman enemmistötienä on vain euron päivä ja muu on sitten tukia vissiin, niin pitäessä saadaan samanlainen tarkastussysteemi kuin maatalouteen, jotta siitä löytyisi ratkaisuja työllistää monia ja ne voisivat vaikka maatalouspuolta siirtyä sinne Palakka puolelle.
tarkistamaan kuinka niiden palakkahommat on suju, löytyykö virheitä vai pitääkö ruveta Karsinmaan palakkoja, jotta tällä se. - Tässä on vaalikeskustot ja aletaan lisääntymään. Ja tulette huomaamaan, että yksikään puolue ei tule kertomaan teille miten lisätään työpaikkoja, kehitellään niitä yhtiöitä.
- Ei pysty, eivät pysty muuta kuin tuumaamaan mistä leikataan. Ja tämä on ollut nyt neljä vuotta trendi ja se tulee jatkuvaan. Oli siellä kuka tahansa hallituksessa ja tietysti jos vasemmisto tulee sinne, tulee lakot lisääntymään ilman muuta. Mutta tämän pistäkään merkille, että nämä etelän voima isojen keskusten äänestäjät ja poliitikot tulevat äänestämään niitä.
Heidän lähialueitaan, ei koko Suomen juttuja. Siellä on puolueiden parhaat voimat, ei Suomen parhaita voimi. Ei muuta, kiitos.
- Vaan löytyyhän noita ryhmiä myös eduskuntatalon ulkopuolelta, joille ihmiset haluavat antaa palautetta tai pitää eräänlaista kehityskeskustelua. Ja sellainenhan onnistui oikein mainosti myös tämän Kansanradion kautta. Oli se ryhmä sitten vaikkapa mainostajat tai sähköpotkulautailijat tai kauppiaat.
Asiaan sitten minun harmittaa, kun minä niin haluaisin niitä kokonaisia maissia mitä voi kriidultata. Missä ovat ihan ne lehdykät ja ne ovat niin helppo keittää suolavedessä ja voilla. Ne vakkumppakkaukset eivät ole maissia, ne eivät pirstahda sinne. Ja toinen on sitten semmoinen niin valkonauriita kun ei tahdo mistään saada.
Kun ne on grillattuna erittäin hyviä sentin palaa ja marinoita ei niitä enää ole, mutta ei tässä tämän enempi. Ei ei.
Jos saada enemmän näitä vastaan ja mitkä vastaisivat puhelimeen niitä, ei sinne pääse koskaan puhelimen kautta, että jotain tarttis tehdä kyllä. Kiitos, hei.
Todella vaarallinen. Kylläden urmeltakin löytyvät ne sähköpostkulautat ettei ajoitelle saa jättää. Kiitos.
erilaisia englanninkielisiä nimiä, niin onko teillä niin paljon siellä englanninkielisiä asiakkaita, että te ette voi enää suomen kielellä ilmoittaa mitä te teette?
Niin koettakaa nyt saada niitä ihmisiä sinne asiakkaaksi, kun te Suomessa kumminkin toimitte. Ja jos te toimitte ulkomailla, niin totta kai te silloin käytätte sen maan kieltä missä te olette. Kiitos suomen kielikunniaan. Moi moi.
Mitäpä postista?
Teille piti tulla Jyväskylän paketti ja se on Jumbossa joka taitaa muuten olla Vantaanpuolella, mutta joka tapauksessa se on. Laittavat viestiä, että nyt se on täällä. Soitettiin, että tytän hoitetaan niin, että se pitää lähettää tänne näin. Joo, se ei ole ihan nopea Jyväskylästä nopea kävelyretki Jumboon. No ei, siinä kaikki vielä. Nyt tuli perjantaina.
Viesti sieltä taas, että nyt se on täällä Jumbossa. Taas? Se oli kaksi lokeroa siitä, nyt kaksi metriä lähemmäksi Jyväskylänsä. No niin, ei ole ihan niin pitkä kävelymatka kumminkaan. Mikäköhän siellä nyt on mennyt Jumiin, kun ei saa sitä lähtemään? No tytär, nyt perjantaina tähän kävi niin kuumana niille, että tästä välttäisi. Se tuleeko näitten kotiovelle kuteen? Siinä kaikki on.
Mä menisin tänä aamuna, niin kun ruvetaan katsoa noita tallenteita, niin ne oli jo sammunut tänään sen, että pääsen verkopankkiin tabletilla, että pääsen laskuja maksamaan. Sekin on pimeänä.
Joo, joo, joo. Napakkaa palautetta postin suuntaan, joo. Mut mä pelkään kaikkia, niin kun se tulee tuohon kotiovelle, niin aukes sen pakkauksen, niin se on kappaleena.
No nyt ei niin huono tuuri voi käydä, että se on sitten vielä hajonnut. No jospa nyt ihan ensimmäisinä saisivat siellä kirjattua ylös, että Jumbo ei sijaitse Jyväskylässä.
Joo, ei mitään. Ei muuta kuin siitä kun kuuntelit ja hyvää päivänjatkoa. Hyvät päivänjatkot. Toivotaan, että paketti tulee ehjänäperille mahdollisimman pidä. Niin kyllä. Näin on. Okei. Moi moi.
No edellä kuvailtu dystopia oli tietysti täysin keksitty, mutta se on vertauskuva sille terrorille, josta tulee käydä. Ja sillä tulee käydä, kun tulee käydä.
Varsinkin kaupallisten radioasemien juontajat harjoittavat loputonta oman äänen kuuntelemista, tyhjänpäiväisten säätietojen tai studion WhatsApp numeroiden toistamista. Jatketaan soitettavan musiikkikappaleen sekä alun että lopun päälle. Jokainen sävellys, olkoon sinfoniaa, iskelmää tai räppiä, se on kokonaisuus, joka on tarkoitettu kuunneltavaksi alusta loppuun asti. Kyllä juontaja ehtii omat höpinänsä höpistä ennen kappaleen ja jälkeen kappaleen.
Ja jos se ei ehdi, niin jättäköön turhat jorinansa pois. Terveisin siis nimimerkki A ja O alku ja loppu.
Niin se olisi rima, olisi pois ja pitäisi keskeyttää periin ja laittaa uusi rima. Siellä ei ole rimaa vaan se on putki, ei sitten muuta.
Kun tuota napatkaan niin äkki, että vanhemmat ihmiset sanoo kaikki, että ei hei kerkeä lukea kuin pikkuisen alusta, niin että siinä olisi kyllä jotain korjaamista. Sillä kaikkihan maksetaan jäsenmaksuja sinne, että no niin, koettaatka panna höpinäksi ja korjitkaa asiat.
Ei, kiitos, ei.
Syntymä, ehkä hääpäivä, että palattaisiko siihen vanhaan systeemiin, että niin. Ei minulla nyt sitten oikein muuta tässä ole, kun hyvää sunnuntaa jatkuu kaikille. Kiitos kuulemiin.
Ja nyt voi puhua vai? Mä nyt sellaista vaan nyt puhun, että toivoisin yleltä, että on tullut joskus tuolta ylentäjällä tämmöinen poliisisarja kuin Donnalle on. Se tulee kaiken maailman telkkarista, mutta ei näinhään ole poliisisarjaa. Tämä sut minä kaipaisin ja varmaan moni.
Ja nyt tämmöinen kuulepa ihan täysin ohi. Quido Brunetti on kuulemma tässä se poliisikomisarja.
Siellä tulee vaikka mitä ihan älyttömiä tommoista, kun ei voi sanoa kuin yksi tähti tai ei mitään, niin minä vaan vertailen niitä muihin sarjaan, että on semmoinen poliisi ja hienosti tehty. Mutta sitten toiseen asiaan, jos tota en mä tiedä voida sanoa, niin katso kun kauhia sitten näitä nuoret nykyään, kun on niin nuorena väkivaltaisia kaikkia, että olisi tämmöinen hyvä juttu. Minä asun kerrostalossa täällä Turussa.
Niin ihmiset olis vähän tai vanhemmat ainakin olis vähän tämmöisiä ystävällisempi näin lapsille ja nuorille. Täällä on niin herttäisi nämä lapset ja kaikkia, vaan ne jotain tekisi niin vähän ojentaessa noin, mutta olisi semmoinen inhimillisempi näin nuorille.
- Oletko sinä siis nähnyt, että lapsia ojennetaan vähän liian kovaa tai heille ollaan jotenkin ilkeitä tai julmia?
- No en mä tuohon niinku semmoista ole nähnyt, mutta mä toivoisin, koska kun ihmetellään, että kun edes tulee tämmöisiä, niin kun ne on niin nuorena väkivaltaisia kaikkia, niin tai siis se johtuu kodista ja varmaan vanhemmistakin, mutta paljon. Mutta mun mielestä ihmisten tarvitsisi olla näille lapsille ja näille semmoinen, ettei saisi olla semmoinen kylmä ja semmoinen väliin pitämätön, että kullakin oli herttäisiä.
Ja kun se tuli tänne niin kauheita noita virpomisoksia, kun oli neljä kun kävi. Ei kun viisi kävi kaikkiaan, niin ne oli niin sulosia ja herttäisiä, että no hyvä juttu, kiitos.
- Hei kiitos paljon kun soitit. Tässä ohjelmassa jos olet kuullut jotain mikä ansaitsee lisäkomenttia, niin minäpä kerron nyt osoitteet, jonne kannattaa sitten viestitellä ja kommentoida. Meidän WhatsApp numero on 044.
5515464. Sähköpostia osoitteeseen kansan.radio@yle.fi. Kirjoittajakorttia kun kirjoittaa, niin sitten kuoreen vaan, että kansanradio pl 7 99 00024 Yleisradio. Ja meidän vastaaja 0800 15464.
Ihmisvastaaja on paikalla kyllä vain kolme tuntia sunnuntaisin heti lähetyksen jälkeen. Vielä vähän tähän kysymyksiä loppuun. Jos näihinkin osaat vastata, niin eikö vaan edellä mainittuihin osoitteisiin ja numeroihin? Näistä kysymyksistä tosin ensimmäiseen minä voin vastata ja se vastaus on, että kyllä, kyllä saa. Lasse Olkinuora toivottaa oikein hyvää päivän jatkoa. Jos saatut kuulemaan tämä vasta yöuusintana, niin sitten oikein hyvää yön jatkoa.
Eli siis oikein hyvä sitä hetkeä missä olet. Tarkennus sitä kesähetkeä missä olet.
Ei saa Suomessa puhua. Hei. Kyösti tällä päivää. Soitan tärkeästä asiasta. Minua ihmetyttävät nuo tumoiset, jotka sanovat itseensä kalastajiksi. Kala lasketaan vammautuneen veteen takaisin. Koukku on repinyt suun hajalle. Fakteerit iskevät siihen. Tämä ei ole mitään kalastusta. Kalamies ottaa sen mitä se saa. Syö.
Tai lahjoittaa toisille, mutta ei heitä sitä takaisin järveen. Tämä pitää laissa kieltää. Tämä pitää mennä maatalousministeriöön tämä asia nyt lävitse, että tämmöinen kalan päästäminen koukusta lopetetaan. Se on kalan kiusaamista. Se ei ole kalastusta. Minä olen kalastanut niin pikkupojasta kuin olla voi isän kanssa.
Kaikki kalat otettiin talteen. Ne syötiin tai lahjoitettiin naapurille, mutta niitä ei heitetty menemään. Alamittaiset myöskin. Ei mulla muuta kuin toivon hyvää kesää ja kireitä siimoja. Hyvä kiitos. Hei.
Ei muuta. Kiitos voi. Kallu täältä hyvinvointialueen reunalta marginaalista. Täällä on tämmöinen ehdotus. Kaikki työttömät poikamiehet tehkää lapsia rikkaiden vaimoille ja heidän tyttärilleen. Näin Suomesta tulee hyvinvointiyhteiskunta, missä köyhät ja rikkaat ovat samassa veneessä.
Hauskaa kesää. Hei hei.